qué expresiones son equivalentes a 6 por
b por w por un medio marca todas las que
apliquen y bueno aquí tengo las opciones
y vamos a marcar las correctas ahora si
nos queremos acercar a esta expresión
que podríamos hacer con esta que tenemos
aquí con la original bueno pues esto
recuerda que es lo mismo si nosotros
cambiamos el orden de los factores que 6
que 6 que multiplica a un medio ok
6 que multiplica un medio que a su vez
multiplicado que a su vez multiplica a w
pero bueno 6 por un medio 6 por un medio
es lo mismo que 3 esto es lo mismo que 3
que multiplica a ver que a su vez
multiplica a doble
y por lo tanto podemos ver que no es la
opción correcta porque aquí está
hablando de una suma mientras que aquí
estamos hablando de una multiplicación y
por lo tanto no podemos llegar a esta
suma de ninguna manera ahora si nos
fijamos en la siguiente opción está si
es correcta de hecho es justo lo que
llegamos llegamos a 3 x
ve por w por lo tanto voy a ponerle una
palomita porque está si es una opción
correcta después tengo 1 por 3 por b por
w + 0 ok
fíjate que aquí tenemos casi esto de
aquí si nosotros multiplicamos esta
expresión de aquí por 1 bueno pues se
sigue manteniendo exactamente igual
porque recuerda que uno es el neutro
multiplicativo entonces voy a
multiplicar por 1 y entonces sigue
siendo la misma expresión y ahora si a
esto yo le agrego 0 si a esto yo les 10
bueno pues date cuenta que sigue siendo
la misma expresión cuando tenemos algo y
le sumamos nada bueno pues seguimos
teniendo este mismo algo por lo tanto
esta era una pregunta capciosa lo único
que nos decían era acomodarlo de una
manera que lo viéramos exactamente igual
y por lo tanto ésta sí es una opción
correcta y nos podemos dar cuenta porque
estamos multiplicando por el neutro
multiplicativo y estamos sumando el
neutro aditivo
tengo esta expresión de aquí abajo wv
por por un medio por seis pero recuerda
que el orden de los factores no afecta
el producto esto de aquí es exactamente
lo mismo que poner si quiero w en un
primer lugar y después se me ocurre
poner bm ok y después él me puede
ocurrir poner a un medio no sé y después
podría poner seis el final llegamos a la
misma expresión porque porque todos se
están multiplicando el orden de los
factores no afecta el producto y
llegamos justo lo mismo esta expresión
aquí es lo mismo que esto de aquí que es
lo mismo que esto de aquí que es lo
mismo que esto de aquí y bueno por lo
tanto le voy a poner una palomita ya
está ya tengo estas tres respuestas
correctas así que vamos el otro
ejercicio y para eso voy a quitar este
ejercicio aquí y voy a borrar la
pantalla déjame borrar la pantalla y
ahora voy a poner el otro ejercicio muy
bien aquí tengo mi otro ejercicio dice
que expresiones son equivalentes a 3 que
multiplica a 4 h más
marc a todas las que apliquen y aquí
tengo cuatro opciones entonces lo
primero que se me ocurre es multiplicar
este 3 por este 4 y este 3 por este 2 k
distribuyendo el 3 y me va a quedar lo
siguiente esto es lo mismo que a 12 h 12
h porque 3 por 4 es 12 más
3 por 12 6 me quedaría 6 k 6 k y bueno
si te das cuenta lo primero que podemos
ver es que esta respuesta es exactamente
lo mismo que esto que tenemos aquí y por
lo tanto está si está en nuestras
respuestas correctas por lo tanto le voy
a poner una palomita
ahora vamos a fijarnos en estas otras
que tenemos por acá
déjame fijarme primero en esta qué te
parece si nosotros distribuimos este 2
multiplicando a laxe y multiplicando el
campo aquí llegaríamos bueno pues 2 x 6
h
esto es lo mismo que dos veces h ok y 2
x 3 camps es lo mismo que seis veces que
seis veces cam y si te das cuenta
es justo lo mismo que tenemos aquí por
lo tanto ésta también es una respuesta
correcta ok entonces déjeme ponerle am
con el mismo color una una palomita de
lujo ahora fijémonos en esta de aquí yo
tengo am 3 que multiplica a 4 camas 2h y
se multiplicó este por este y este por
éste a que voy a llegar bueno 3 x 4
es lo mismo que 12 12 veces camps y
después tengo 3 x 2 h lo cual es seis
veces h
y aquí aquí llegamos a que no es lo
mismo si te das cuenta esta expresión es
12 veces camps más seis veces h cuando
realmente tengo doce veces h + seis
veces
camps por lo tanto esta no es una de mis
respuestas correctas le voy a echar
llegará muy bien fijar en esta expresión
que tengo aquí abajo 3 que multiplica a
24 h y que me quedaría si yo multiplico
este 3 por este de aquí y este 3 por
este de aquí bueno pues me va a quedar
lo mismo que 3 por 2
es 6 veces que ok
y después tengo a más 3 por 4 es 12
veces h que si te das cuenta es justo lo
mismo de camps si aplicamos la con mucha
actividad en la suma 12 veces
6 veces camps es lo mismo que seis veces
camas 12 veces h y por lo tanto éste
también tiene una pequeña paloma de lujo
entonces ya tenemos la respuesta
correcta como están muy sencillos déjame
hacer otro par más de ejercicios vamos a
ser el siguiente déjame quitar este
ejercicio de aquí y voy a hacer el
siguiente ejercicio
vamos a traer el siguiente problema que
es este que tengo aquí y vamos a ver qué
me dice llena los espacios en blanco
para crear una expresión equivalente a 6
que multiplica a 3 b más w ok pues qué
te parece si lo primero que se me ocurre
es que podemos distribuir este 6 o
esperan déjame cambiar la herramienta
voy a distribuir este 6 multiplicando a
este 3 b y después voy a tomarme este 6
multiplicando
w y por lo tanto qué es lo que me va a
quedar bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 6
por 3 es 18 18 veces ven ya esto le voy
a sumar 6 por top león lo cual es más
seis veces w por lo tanto si llenamos
los espacios me va a quedar 18 veces am
aquí voy a poner un 18 18 veces ven más
seis veces w por lo tanto este espacio
en blanco lo voy a llenar con un 6 y ya
está aquí tenemos la respuesta de este
otro problema así que hagamos uno más
voy a traer ahora a este problema que
tengo aquí y vamos a ver qué me dice la
expresión a 3 que multiplica a 12 efe
más que más 4 es equivalente a 6 veces
efe
más tres veces que más 12 bueno pues
vamos a aplicar otra vez nuestra
propiedad distributiva voy a multiplicar
este 3 por este 12 efe también voy a
multiplicar este 3 por esta gema y
también voy a multiplicar a este 3 por
este 4 porque este 3 multiplica
los sumandos que estén adentro del
paréntesis y que me va a quedar bueno
pues esto lo mismo que tres por dos f
eso es seis veces f ok ya esto tres
porque bueno eso es lo mismo que tres
veces que a esto le sumamos tres veces
gente y por último tengo tres por 4 3
por 4 es lo mismo que dos entonces me
quedan 6 veces efe
más tres veces que más 12 que es
exactamente lo mismo lo que tengo aquí
por lo tanto ya puedo concluir que esta
expresión de aquí en efecto es
equivalente a esta otra expresión que
tengo aquí entonces podemos poner sí sí
son equivalentes y como si son
equivalentes es hora de acabar este
vídeo ya llegamos a la respuesta
correcta